welcome to this video playing all of our
alonso with black nylon so yeah go Joe
try to use the fact that he has not
played see form gaining some space on
the queenside quickly this is kind of
this is a respectable opening it looks a
bit wacky but it is go okay not sure
about the precise move otter but in
general it is believed to be okay before
giant problem hard to play something
else now at this black has gained some
nice space on the queenside just hope
that I'm not suffering from weaknesses
there but it should be okay you should
probably take before and play Bishop f4
try to play on the CFL it's also
interesting gaining some space okay
Bishop a6 kind of a where else where
else should this Bishop go at least hits
looking at the e2 pole
96 96 looking at a five or rather 9797
makes some sense yes so that I may be
can be captured with the night i also
have qu 8 Queen B 5 this kind of setup I
think I should be reasonably okay in
this position efore really maybe yeah
let's let's clarify this if he's taking
or not okay so he's looking at the c6
square Bishop g6 to have to trade it or
I can also play Bishop to b5 just to
cover c6 now maybe maybe not such a bad
idea also prevents queen a for any Queen
activation
okay you have to this night is something
I have to get rid of maybe he's going
for Knight f3
okay let's keep it simple don't do
anything fancy maybe you can take by the
pawn actually 494 night that he doesn't
ok so I wanted to really do the simple
stuff like here and take this annoyed
it's not very ambitious but not bad ok
yeah I can take it just very simple but
also very boring so let's not be too
boring here preparing groups is seven
rook c8
he's taking lots of time really can
really argue is he playing even slower
than I am okay so he's she threatening
to take Paul maybe looks why is ruth
retina to take take take take Jim
ticking is very boring taking all the
three I mean is be three mo voices too
ambitious for Roxy to that's probably
not leading to anything
mm-hm ticking ticking is really boring
maybe I can hey I can give up the pony
for some activity or so I don't know
from Queen B 5 and somewhere it's
possible that's actually really possible
cakes if it takes before I'm taking e to
play Queen B 5 this is this is some some
very decent activity for the pawn
queen bee 593 Quincy to was my idea was
thinking that it should be a decent
compensation with Roxy to and the in the
mix maybe I can click we give one maybe
yeah I can yeah this is a case where I
probably shouldn't have given up the
pole hmm I didn't see didn't see the
this move really the screen move okay if
I take take this i'm going to be in an
awkward pin rooks III here night c5f
queen before my day six is very awkward
okay yeah that was I really violated the
keep it simple method very clearly
gotten gotten myself into some some
issues maybe it's still okay here with
this proxy form I don't think I can play
for winning in any case we should be
fine this is just a bad self pin or not
Bishop before look be to gym it's not
going to work game god I don't think I
can do anything anything here here i can
actually is it stupid I can take here I
can take on before here I totally forgot
that I can just take that that I'm not
gonna then I'm not in a fog anymore yeah
I'm just just having the better game oh
ok yeah this was this was i was just
thinking that was room basically here
there was a situation where i can still
take quite waking them I was always
thinking I mean I mean some kind of fork
we had so it is it is okay i just have
to take care kind of weird that i didn't
didn't consider this move Oh somehow I
still had in mind that i have an loop
here in this night this night a six
coming okay so i think it was a pretty
equal ish position anyway here I'm
okay I've got the space on the queenside
and he really cannot do much but it's a
very tricky business and trying to to
play for when I tried a bit with giving
up the pawn and actually would have
gotten some way I could just take I
really really had a hallucination they
are thinking that there was some some
problem problem here yeah okay a draw
there have to be some drawers thanks for
watching